SERVIC
MANU RAJU, CNNPIXY
WAR ALD D LIST FORMEIDT  PENTIO
CAIDATES IIZMIMARY GOVERNOR
PREVIEW  WHATENTIAL 24HE
LO IN MA W I CANAY
THLY, IN YOU
MANY W, THE RHOSTHAN THE D.
TELL YOU D YOUR GOVERNOR DOUGN.
ITILY AND N HAENI KE YOUR
>> ESPECIALLY GREAT TORERANKLY A
VERNOR DOUU, FOR EIGHT YEARS OF
LEADERSHIP.WS WHAT I D WHAT
S CEONE
BE R OY ONE TO LEAD EATE
FOS WITH KRISTEN HOLMES
SCOTTSDALE FON
>> Repte
MANY REPUBLICAS A BATTLE OR E
TO DO AND O
SIDE DONALUME KARI WITH  LS ANCH
HAVE PRESIUPPORTING KARRIN T
SUPPOR.E REPUBLICAN WO
YEMPRE A TEA
>>ZONAE .ET OUT ANDOTE FOR
RRROBSON, U N ND A DEAFENING ME
AMERICA, THAT THE BL
R COUNTRY IS R OGG
G SYSTEMATLY DESTROYED
>>E TALKING OU
F THE  TYESTERDAY,
FORWARD, THAT THIS RA W.
AT THER PRESIDENT.
BUT ALL OF THIS PROXR THAT HPEIN
EM
STFO ONALD TRUMP 02PENC
RECE WEEKS THERET THERE
MIGHSIDENT IN
GO ANOA F , BUT WHEN HE TH
KE A